the biden administration seeks new mask
and vaccine mandates as they wildly
misconstrue the data on the delta
variant surge
and joe biden's got a huge inflation
problem i'm ben shapiro this is the
bench bureau show the ben shapiro show
is sponsored by expressvpn protect your
online privacy today at expressvpn.com
ben speaking of which have you ever read
the fine print that appears when you
start browsing in incognito mode
it says your activity might actually
still be visible to like your employer
your school your isp
how can they even call it incognito to
really stop people from seeing the sites
you visit
you need to do what i do and use
expressvpn think about all the times
you've used wi-fi at a coffee shop a
hotel even at your parents house without
expressvpn every site you visit could be
logged by the admin of that network that
is still true even when you are in
incognito mode it means you really want
your parents your friends your family
your isp to see what you are doing
online frankly it's none of their
business
what's more your home internet provider
can also see and record
your browsing data in the us they are
legally allowed to sell that data to
advertisers expressvpn however is an app
that encrypts all of your network data
and then re-routes it through a network
of secure servers so your private online
activity stays
just that private your privacy is
important to you it's important to
express vpn
as well expressvpn works on all your
devices it's really easy to use one
click you've downloaded it another click
and now it is
working on your computer or your phone
or any of your other smart devices stop
letting strangers invade your online
privacy today protect yourself
at expressvpn.com use my link
expressvpn.com to get three extra months
for free that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
to learn more alrighty so we have a
serious case of institutional mistrust
that has broken out in this country with
regard to the cdc with regard to the nih
and that mistrust is well founded it is
well placed dr rochelle wolensky of the
cdc is garbage at her job dr anthony
fauci is garbage at his job they are
just purveying this information at this
point now the narrative you have been
told
is that the misinformation on covet is
coming predominantly from the right
if that were true then presumably there
would be this huge
partisan gap not an ending partisan gap
between democrats and republicans now
there is
a partisan gap in vaccinations between
democrats and republicans however
a huge percentage of the people who are
unvaccinated at this point
are in fact democrats and that includes
a disproportion a disproportionate
number of black
and hispanic citizens who certainly are
not watching tucker carlson
okay so why is this happening the reason
this is happening is because the same
people who are telling you to get a
vaccine
are simultaneously telling you the
vaccines don't work the same people who
are telling you that you need to mask up
after having a vaccine are
simultaneously simultaneously telling
you that you're an idiot
for not getting the vaccine in the first
place and this is ridiculous
it is you don't trust your institutional
actors because at this point they're not
showing you the data you know what a
good scientist does
shows you the data i feel like cuba
gooding jr
in in jerry maguire at this point show
me the data that's all
i'm more than happy to take whatever
precautions you recommend so long as the
precautions are steeped in data
and backed by data i'm not going to
listen to dr rochelle wolinski
because she's the head of the cdc i'm
going to listen to her if she makes a
convincing argument
but is saying things right now that are
just not factually true
and the same thing is true of the
vaunted and sainted dr anthony fauci
and yet the media's take of course is
that it is solely mistrust
bred by the right that is causing the
vaccine hesitancy in the united states
here's chuck todd of msnbc making that
case yesterday for example
i fear that the reckoning is here this
is the reckoning we
the the trust the campaign of of
mistrust that was
waged against those of us in mainstream
journalism by
what's happened in the right wing for
the last decade unfortunately
our reckoning is in an icu um
way too way way too close to many of our
lives okay so first of all let's just
talk
once again about the death from coveted
stats okay because i think it's
important for you to know
where we currently stand right now the
seven day rolling average of death in
the united states
remains at 316 according to the new york
times
okay that is up from about a month ago
but it is not up from two months ago
when it was about that is we've
essentially been pretty flat
in terms of the number of diagnosed
cases in the united states the diagnosed
cases in the united states are up pretty
wildly the seven-day rolling average
about 51 000 cases
but are we in crisis mode if we're
having 300 deaths today
from covid first of all there are plenty
of good epidemiologists including dr
scott gottlieb
who's been former head of the fda he's
been out there saying that he thinks a
couple more weeks and the delta variant
is basically blown through the system
and
we're kind of done okay but panic has
set in in the biden administration
and they're seizing control of the means
of production essentially so
and they're doing so by preventing bad
data so they've now said that you need
to mask up your kids
that if you're vaccinated you still need
to mask up which is which is wild and
anti-data and they're doing this on the
basis
of bad or no data okay the data i'm
about to present to you
are from the cdc the data that i'm about
to present you are from
actual studies in places like the new
england journal of medicine the things
that are that dr wolenski
is saying right now and dr fauci is
saying right now are not
evidenced so for example rochelle
willenski she says you know what
maybe we you know the real reason that
we need to mask up the vaccinated
the real reason that we're recommending
vaccinate that vaccinated people mask up
is because vaccinated people could get
breakthrough
and she's asked at what rate the rate
you're about to hear rachelle wolenski
trot out
for vaccinated people getting
breakthrough cases is off
by a magnitude of about let's see 500 i
believe
is the number here she is just giving a
stat that is completely wrong
if you're a vaccinated person you have
um and you're in one of those areas as
you said a sea
of red a sea of covid you have a
reasonable high
chance if nobody's wearing a mask to
interact with people who may be
infectious and
so for every 20 people one or two of
them
could get a breakthrough infection for
every 20 vaccinated people one or two of
them could get a breakthrough infection
um they may only get mild disease but we
wanted them to know that they could
bring that mild disease home they could
bring it to others
okay so she said right there 1 in 10 or
one in 20.
it's like ten percent of people who've
been vaccinated will get a breakthrough
infection according to dr richard
wolenski
ten percent what is the actual percent
of people who are going to get
breakthrough infections in the united
states thus far
this is according to the centers for
disease control she's the head of it
okay this is according to the cdc i'm
quoting her own agency now
quote with more than 156 million
americans fully vaccinated nationwide
approximately 153 000 symptomatic
breakthrough cases are estimated to have
occurred as of last week
that represents point zero nine eight
percent
of those fully vaccinated okay so
there's a rather large difference
between
10 and 100 1 in 10 vaccinated people
getting coveted symptomatically and
one in ten thousand okay that
that is what the stat is right now right
now one in a hundred now one in a
thousand
one in ten thousand people in the united
states who have been fully vaccinated
have gotten some sort of breakthrough
infection symptomatic breakthrough
infection by the way how many of those
people have actually been hospitalized
according to the cdc about six thousand
about six thousand people out of 160
million vaccinated
so one in every 25 000 people or so is
going to get a symptomatic breakthrough
infection so bad they have to be
hospitalized and much lower than that
in cases of death but she's using this
in order to argue that you need to mask
up
okay that is covered misinformation is
she going to get tossed off of youtube
is she going to get tossed off of
facebook she is a vaccine denier
she is hands high facts she's giving you
bad data
she's not even quoting her own agency
you know why they're doing this the
answer is i think you're an idiot that's
really why they're doing this they think
that you're a fool
and you can't do risk assessment and so
for some reason they think that it is a
good
idea to tell you lies about the efficacy
of the vaccine in order to get you to
take the vaccine which doesn't even make
sense as a tactic
if you want people to get vaccinated
what you tell them is the truth the
vaccines are unbelievably effective they
are a medical miracle
and and if you get it you're largely
protected and you go back to life that's
how you get people to get vaccinated
you know how you don't get people to get
vaccinated you know if you get
vaccinated you're gonna have to wear a
mask the rest of your life and by the
way your danger factor is still pretty
high like what in the world are they
doing
maybe they just feel like if they
control your life at every turn because
you can't control your own life or do
your own risk assessment they're better
off
but it's dictatorial totalitarian crap
based not in any sense i mean that's
just
that is anti-evidence anti-evidence on
that basis for shoveling says let's mask
the children
again children the evidence that
children ought to be masked is
really really skimpy hey children are
bad at wearing masks
children are uncomfortable in masks
children should not be wearing masks in
95 degree weather outside you know who
used to know this dr fauci like as of
last year
under 350 kids under the age of 18 have
died from kovad this entire time in a
subpopulation
of 75 million people and here she is
saying you need to ask your kids
presumably to protect the adult who
won't get the vaccine while dealing with
infectious people like again that is
your choice you don't want to do that
that's fine but i'm not going to mask up
my three-year-old
i'm not i have a seven to five and one
i'm not gonna mask up any of those kids
in order to protect you if you don't
wanna get the vaccine and by the way
here's the amazing thing
i have not met a single unvaccinated
person who
who is trying to request that i mask my
child to protect them
it is only controlling totalitarians
like rochelle wallensky
who say that i need to mask up my child
so that a 45 year old who doesn't want
to get vaccinated
can feel safe she's really i mean which
as we'll see is really just the talk of
the teachers unions here's rachelle
willenski saying
children what we're now seeing with this
transmissible delta variant
is um you know 12 to 17 year olds now we
still have about 30 percent
of those vaccinated so we haven't seen
the vaccination rates in those people we
now have a very
high transmission the majority of people
in our schools right now will be
unvaccinated just by virtue of the
numbers and we felt that it was really
important
to lean in and try and have our children
back to school in the safest way
possible
and that would mean masking by the way
they're not going to bring the kids back
to school they're just not going to
in fact randy wine i mean the cdc wrote
its school standards
at the behest of the american federation
of teachers run by randy weingarten
here's randy weingarten yesterday
who won't commit to reopening the
schools remember 40
of all school teachers in new york city
the epicenter of the epidemic
are still not vaccinated they don't want
to go back to school this is all
political
here's randy weingarten saying openly
well you know maybe maybe they won't go
back to school maybe there won't be
school
anymore ever again first of all fine you
want to do this
i am more than happy to keep my kids in
private school and we should be setting
up school voucher programs where all the
money that we were going to spend
at the public school to follow your to
follow the school
should be spent on the kid just give the
money back to the parents the parents
can send their kids to a parochial
school
here's randy weingarten saying the you
know refusing to say whether they're
opening this
it's so political it's so and so
non-data-driven
kids not being able to get vaccines
um 12 and under has really thrown this
curveball
that says that while vaccine is
vaccination is the number one gold
standard
that we need to you know bring back our
mass for schools
so the bottom line is we're going to
keep kids safe
we're going to keep our members safe and
we're going to try to open up schools
and we're going to try to move through
this political battlefield no you're not
your political battlefield is how do i
get my teachers paid without them ever
having to go to work again
that's what the teachers are directly
opposed in these unions
to the interests of the students
meanwhile i got dr anthony fauci the
greatest of all doctors outside of dr
joel biden saying that you should wear a
mask even though you're vaccinated
remember two weeks ago he was saying
that if you're vaccinated you don't need
to wear a mask
and two weeks before that he was saying
you should wear a mask if you're
vaccinated
as we'll see he denies that he has ever
flip-flopped because he's a liar here's
dr fauci
the recommendations and the guidelines
have been changed to say that if you are
vaccinated
even though you are vaccinated you are
in an indoor
public setting in an area of the country
with a high degree
of viral dynamics namely the red
and orange sections on the cdc chart
then you need to wear a mask
even though you are vaccinated
okay and then he says we're not
flip-flopping on this and because
they lie to you i mean that's all i can
say he's lying this is not true
something has changed and what has
changed is the virus
the cdc hasn't changed and the cdc
hasn't really flip-flopped at all
what's happened is that when that
earlier recommendation was made we were
dealing predominantly
with the alpha variant however now
we are dealing with a delta variant
which is really quite
a lot more transmissible than the alpha
variant
okay so he says that the data have
changed except that the data have not
changed
the data have not changed the main
vectors of transmission
in society are not the vaccinated
and then fauci backs this up by saying
well you know what we're seeing is that
viral loads are really high from the
delta variant
as we'll see there are no data to back
this up he's just saying this stuff
when you go back 60 days or the two
months ago
when you look at the level of virus in
the nasopharynx
of a person who's vaccinated and gets a
breakthrough infection
it was considerably less than the level
of virus in the nasopharynx of an
unvaccinated person the data were clear
now that we have a delta variant that
has
changed the entire landscape because
when you look at the level of virus
in the nasopharynx of a vaccinated
person who gets a breakthrough infection
with delta
it is exactly the same as the level of
virus
in a unvaccinated person who's infected
okay but the problem is he does not make
it clear whether the viral load
being carried by the vaccinated person
is as infectious
okay it is not merely a question of
viral load it's whether this is
infectious
viral load so people dug into the actual
cdc stats here and here is what they
found they found
that the cdc had cited an indian study
to support this idea that the viral load
was really high
in breakthrough infections from the
delta variant
there's only one problem the study was
done
first of all it was retracted the study
itself was bad and it was retracted
second of all the study itself was done
on the basis of a vaccine that is not
legal to use in the united states
it was the wrong vaccine and the study
was retracted
i mean this is nuts according to
stat which is a news source quote an
administration official speaking on the
condition of anonymity
told stat health experts do not have
studies proving that fully vaccinated
people are transmitting the virus
rather the official said the updated
guidance is based on studies showing
that vaccinated people who contract the
delta variants have similarly high
levels of virus in their airways
which suggested they may be infectious
to others with other variants vaccinated
people had substantially lower levels of
virus in their noses and throats
compared to unvaccinated people
okay so they know that there's a higher
viral but they don't know whether that's
infectious viral load
all of which is prompting the washington
post to ask where is the data
the washington post is asking where's
the data we'll get to that in just
one second first let's talk about the
fact you don't want to go to the auto
parts store today we're pretty much ever
why
you stand in line finally get to the
front answer a bunch of questions and
then they'll be like you know what we
don't have that in stock but we can
order it for you and we can up charge
you
or you could just go to the internet and
get the part yourself go to rockauto.com
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing
prices based on what the market will
bear like airlines do
well i spend up to twice as much for the
same parts they're a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years
go to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers
the catalog's unique and remarkably easy
to navigate quickly see all the parts
available for your vehicle and choose
the brands
specifications and prices you prefer go
to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
right shapiro in there how did you hear
about usbox so they know
that we sent you again no reason to
stand in line get up charged have to
wait to get the part in the mail anyway
go back to the store
instead just get the part you need at
the best available price that's what
rockauto.com
does great american business head on
over to rockauto.com right now see all
the parts available
for your car or truck and write shapiro
in there how did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you okay so
here is what the washington post writes
even the washington post is like um guys
this
like this is coming from nowhere new
recommendations from federal health
officials this week on when vaccinated
americans should don face masks
came with a startling bolt of news
people who have had their shots and
become infected with the delta variant
of the coronavirus can harbor large
amounts of virus just like unvaccinated
people
that means they could become spreaders
of the disease and should return to
wearing masks indoors in certain
situations
including when vulnerable people are
present okay so first of all even if
vaccinated people are infectious that
still does not mean
that vaccinated people should be wearing
the masks at this point the reason i say
this
is because it is now your responsibility
as an unvaccinated person to take into
account
the risks in life you know when people
have the flu
many people stay home some people don't
let people have a cold a lot of people
go to work
with a cold because you can work through
a cold okay do we mandate that everybody
mask up at all times
i mean that's really the limiting
principle here if you could infect
somebody with anything
do you have to mask up for the rest of
time is this the new rule because the
vaccine is now available to
all the adults if you are vaccinated
let's say that you're vaccinated and
let's say you can even pass this thing
but everybody around you has the ability
to protect themselves by getting a
vaccine
is it your obligation to wear a mask to
prevent somebody
who doesn't feel like getting vaccinated
from getting vaccinated
is that now is that how we are going to
operate i mean serious question is that
how we're going to operate in the united
states but
put that aside is there even evidence to
support this notion
that the vaccinated are our main vectors
of transmission that they get break
through infections at a at a one in ten
rate as reshovelenski falsely says
and that even if they have those
breakthrough infections they're now
transmitting the virus at the same rate
as the unvaccinated
here's the washington post the centers
for disease control and prevention did
not publish the new research
in the text of the updating masking
guidance the agency merely cited quote
cdc covet 19 response team unpublished
data 2021.
some outside scientists have their own
message show us the data
greg gonsalves an associate professor at
the yale school of public health
who is not a conservative says they are
making a claim that people with delta
who are vaccinated and unvaccinated
have similar levels of viral load but
nobody knows what that means
it's meaningless unless we see the data
according to a federal official
knowledgeable about the research but who
is not authorized to be a spokesperson
for the government quote the data will
be published imminently
the data were alarming and recently
presented the official said we saw the
data and thought it was urgent enough to
act in the context of a steeply rising
preventable surge
of covet 19. because tests showed
similar levels of virus in the
vaccinated and unvaccinated
the cdc inferred the delta variant can
be transmitted by people
with breakthrough infections fauci said
i think the implications are that people
who are vaccinated even when they're
asymptomatic
can still transmit the virus but
but okay here here's the big but as
as mc hammer might say here's the big
butt
fauchi noted there is not yet clinical
data
on what the high viral loads mean in
terms of disease
transmission
let me read that again slowly for those
of you who are
who are listening to positive america
fauci noted
there is not yet clinical data on what
the high viral loads mean
in terms of disease transmission
that means that even if you have a high
viral load we don't have any data
on whether that high viral load is being
detected
and whether that high viral load is
actually transmissible you could still
be carrying a high viral load but it's
not particularly transmissible because
your body did a good job of killing off
the virus
factory said you can make a reasonable
assumption that vaccinated people can
transmit the virus
just like unvaccinated people can can
you make reasonable assumptions it's
just a question
because i have a reasonable assumption
that reasonable assumption is that for
example
if you've had covet 19 and then you get
over covered 19
your body has developed a level of
immunity voucher won't make that
assumption but he'll make the assumption
that if a vaccinated person has a high
viral load it's exactly the same as an
unvaccinated person having a
having a high viral load what's the
evidence to back it up he presents none
it's a reasonable quote-unquote
assumption three senior administration
officials who spoke on the condition of
anonymity said the new research
convinced health officials it was time
to update the agency's guidance
that's not true okay what happened here
is that you were seeing an uptick in
communities and you have
health actors who don't trust the
american people and so they say
everybody needs to mask up again
this was not driven by new data this was
driven by the pure panic button
controlling top-down mentality of people
in the public health establishment
when scientists compared viral loads and
vaccinated and unvaccinated
individuals infected with an early
variant of the virus the alpha variant
there were considerable differences in
the amount of virus each carried the cdc
did not answer questions wednesday
about whether it relied on outside
sources of data or the number of
patients examined in its outbreak
investigations okay this is one of the
questions because as i mentioned
the cdc seemed to rely on an indian
study that was retracted
in their internal paperwork the medical
and scientific community has generally
endorsed the change in cdc mask
guidance the questions about viral loads
is among many unknowns surrounding cyrus
kova ii
including the frequency of breakthrough
infections and whether they play a
significant role in the recent rise in
cases
robert wachter chair of the department
of medicine at university of california
berkeley he said
if we're seeing more breakthroughs is it
just because the virus is better and the
vaccines don't hold up quite as well or
is the efficacy of the vaccines
beginning to wane independent of delta
and then wallenski says the big concern
is that the next variant that might
emerge just a few mutations away could
eventually evade
our vaccine okay so there is no end
point here there is no endpoint here
um and i guess that's the idea you're
supposed to listen to them they don't
have to release the data
they don't have to tell you why they're
doing what they're doing they don't have
to present evidence
that even if there are higher higher
viral loads that those viral loads
are as transmissible as for the
unvaccinated they don't have to do any
of that they can just tell you what to
do
and you have to listen and then they
will label you an idiot label you an
idiot if they don't present you with an
actual argument
on the back of all of this jibber-jabber
about how everyone is going to die of
the delta variant and again
let me remind you these vaccine it's
amazing
i'm like the opposite of a quote-unquote
vaccine denier i think these vaccines
are incredibly effective
in fact according to research square.com
they put together a really cool chart
showing
how much a risk is lowered from cova 19
after taking the vaccine
okay basically number one if you are
below the age
of 30 you are less likely
to die of covid unvaccinated than every
other age group in the united states
vaccinated
and so we should start with that we're
talking about like at a rate of 0.0001
okay 0.0001 percent of people who are
unvaccinated under the age of 30 will
die of covet
those are very very low numbers nobody
stops their life
to prevent the chance of a point zero
zero zero one percent chance of dying
nobody does that okay but how effective
are these vaccines
if you are at the age of 30 then your
risk
from death of covet 19 goes from point
zero zero one percent
which is one in about let's see
100 one in a thousand one ten thousand
one hundred thousand
about one in one hundred thousand if you
are at the age of 30 like below the age
of 35
okay it goes from that to point zero
zero zero one percent
okay if you're 35 it goes from like
point zero zero five percent
all the way down to close to zero and
now if you go and the higher you go
the more the the risk is higher at the
baseline and then the more the risk is
is reduced
on a percentage basis so if you're 55
you had a nearly 0.1 percent chance of
death
from covet 19 before vaccination and now
you're down to like a point zero zero
five percent chance
of death from the vaccine after
post-vaccine
so that means that your risk factors
have dropped by a factor of about 20.
the vaccines are incredibly incredibly
effective but we are now supposed to
we're now told that vaccines are less
effective
which is a terrible pitch for people to
get the vaccine
okay so the this has led to a sort of
box canyon
for for a lot of the members of the left
on the one hand they keep down playing
the efficacy of the vaccine
on the other hand they want to force you
to get the vaccine okay you don't you
wouldn't have to force people to get the
vaccine if you just
made clear how effective the vaccine is
you wouldn't and if people chose to get
unvaccinated and go about their daily
business
that would be their choice instead you
got this box canyon as i say
of we are going to not give you any data
the data we give you are going to be
wrong half the time
we're going the data are going to be
wrong in the direction of saying that
the vaccine is less effective
rather than more effective and also now
we have to force you to get the vaccine
this is where bill de blasio comes in
the idiot mayor of new york city here he
was explaining
that it's time to to mandate
vaccinations
we've got to shape people at this point
and say come on now
we tried voluntary you know we could not
have been more
kind and compassionate as a country free
testing
everywhere you turn incentives friendly
warm embrace the voluntary phase
is over we can keep doing those things
i'm not saying shut it down
i'm saying voluntary alone doesn't work
it's time for mandates because it's the
only way to protect our people
or you could theoretically just say
number one if you're vaccinated you're
protected and number two
you could stop lying about how the
vaccinated are the real vectors of
transmission
and the vaccinated are like they've
they've split the message and in
splitting the message
they've undermined their own trust and
not only that they've undermined
confidence in the power of the vaccine
in the first place
nancy pelosi is doing the same thing she
announced a mass mandate in the house
again now here's the thing
i believe every democrat in the house
has had the vaccine at this point
so i'm not sure exactly what she's
worried about but
this is about control at this point when
people when people don't give you the
rationale for why they are doing what
they are doing
when they won't give you the rationale
for why you must follow their rules
that means that they are authoritarian
okay this is authoritarian nonsense
here's nancy pelosi announcing
that everybody in the house is going to
mask up again everybody in that
again the entire senate i believe every
single senator in the u.s senate
is vaccinated at this point every
democrat in the house is vaccinated
i believe most of the republican house
members are vaccinated if they're not
that's their problem but here's nancy
pelosi saying
that she's going to mandate masks on the
house floor again
consistent with the newly updated
guidance from the office of the
attending fellow
physician related to the increased
threat
from the delta variant of the virus the
chair wishes to inform all members and
staff that mask once again be required
in the hall
of the house members are reminded that
under house resolution 38
the sergeant-at-arms is authorized and
directed to impose a fine
against any member acting in violation
of this policy
so they're going to find people now okay
at this point it is just about the
control so kevin mccarthy said okay our
guys aren't masking
like we're not doing that anymore we're
done so nancy pelosi called him a
because this is this is
so much of this right now is about not
convincing people
so much of this is not about getting
people vaccinated it is not about
restoring people's freedoms it's not
about giving people freedom of choice
and respecting them as individual human
beings
it is about control and othering and
treating everybody who thinks
differently than you
as a bad person the masks have become a
sign
that you are a grade a student that
you're the kid who gets the gold star in
class as my friend john pot horace said
on the commentary magazine podcast
for people who are wearing the mask at
this point vaccinated particularly
this is just another sign that you
adhere to the regime
that that knows best for you you you
listen to the quote-unquote experts
now here's the thing if the experts
don't present your data they're not
they're not much kind of expert
and if they've shifted their position a
thousand times based on the same data
they're not super expert are they but
here's nancy pelosi saying that anyone
who won't mask up including the
vaccinated is some sort of
mask mandate speaker pelosi any response
to the backlash
for the response that's the purview of
the capital physician the official
capacity uh mandate from him but i have
nothing
to say about that except we honor it
leader mccarthy
leader mccarthy says it's against the
science
he's such a says nancy pelosi
mccarthy responded by saying weird
because you weren't wearing a mask like
in the middle of the pandemic when
you're getting your hair cut
correct the mask is now the sign of
virtue for a lot of people
the mask is the sign of virtue you're a
better person if you wear the mask
the mask is just a tool the mask is just
a tool that you are supposed to use in
certain circumstances
in order to prevent transmission when
there's no vaccine available
you want to encourage people to get the
vaccine the vaccination tell people that
they are on their own and they get to
make free decisions and then they can do
risk assessments
you know many people have come up to me
who are unvaccinated in the past couple
of weeks thanks to the uptick in delta
and said they are now thinking about
getting vaccinated a lot
you know why because they're afraid of
getting it because that's the way that
people assess risk
but they don't want you to assess risk
they don't want you to use individual
judgment they don't want you to make
judgment based on science they want to
tell you what to do and not tell you why
they are telling you what
what to do that's what they want and
that's ugly and it's un-american it
really is
present the evidence for why you are
recommending what you're recommending
and then i'll take it seriously
otherwise shut the f
up alrighty we'll get to more on this
and just so we'll get to the bipartisan
infrastructure bill
in just a second first i'm thrilled to
announce that my
new book the authoritarian moment is now
on sale it is available everywhere books
are purchased
it is one of the biggest bestsellers in
the country i couldn't have written this
book in a more important time in our
country's history
as the left increases their iron grip on
our institutions entertainment education
even the way we interact with one
another our country is becoming more and
more divided
more susceptible to authoritarian
control our chief example today of
course the cdc continuing to put
mandates on masks without even
presenting you the evidence
creating an us versus them mentality
based on an ever-changing narrative
that's spreading like a disease
throughout the citizen
body politic it's just another stepping
stone toward authoritarianism we need to
fight back now it's time to read up on
the truth in order to stand up to these
crazy leftists the authoritarian moment
is now available at amazon barnes noble
or any other major bookseller go get
your copy
right now and leave a five star review
to let others know this book is worth
their time i really appreciate it also
guys i know the world is under attack by
authoritarian leftists i have some great
news for you
if you've ever thought it would be cool
to travel on the daily wires time to our
studios in nashville to smoke a cigar
with the host
you might just be in luck because if
you're not a member yet this
is your moment head on over to
dailywire.com subscribe
use code backstage to get 25 off your
new membership and be automatically
entered to win
two tickets to lounge with the daily
wire legends backstage
that is not all you also get to take
home a signed copy of my brand new book
the authoritarian moment and if none of
that entices you just remember
you unlike most people will get to meet
me
oh yeah so head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe with code backstage to get 25
off your membership and a chance to win
the ultimate backstage experience
i've got even more good news for you if
you're not a cigar smoker or you already
have a signed copy of my book you can
enter to win a free trip to the daily
wear studio to meet candace owens and
see her live show
if you sign up now as a daily wire
member with code vip you'll get 25
off your new membership and be
automatically entered for a chance to
win a trip for two to daily water
studios to see candace live
you won't only be meeting candace you'll
also be getting an inside look at her
studio
front row seats to watch her destroy the
left's flimsy narratives on her talk
show candace
it's a good time on candace's sets so
this isn't an opportunity
i'd pass up were i you so if you're in
the mood for a vacation with a side of
leftist takedowns go enter now to win
two vip tickets to candace
dailywire.com subscribe using code vip
for 25
off you are listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
okay so final note on the supposed delta
spike that's going to kill us all
so much so that the vaccinated have to
remask so britain is a few weeks ahead
of us
on this britain had this major coveted
spike right so if you look at the case
rate
in great britain with regard to covet
about two weeks ago
they were up even a week ago they're up
at like 50 000 cases a day which was up
near the height of where they had been
during the worst of the pandemic for
them
last january they were like 60 000 cases
a day their seven day rolling average
about that time
again just as of last week they're up to
about 50 000 cases a day there's only
one
problem with the narrative that this
continues forever and that we're going
to have to mask up in all of this
and that is the delta variant stopped in
britain
according to the washington post quote
this is a puzzler
coronavirus cases are plummeting in
britain they were supposed to soar
scientists aren't sure why they haven't
but i've been told the scientists know
everything that they know everything
and that is why you have to listen to
them the daily number of new infections
recorded in the country fell for seven
days in a row before a slight uptick on
wednesday
when the country reported 27 734 cases
that's still almost half of where the
caseload was a week ago
the trajectory of the virus in britain
is something the world is watching
closely and anxiously
as a test of how the delta variant
behaves in a society with relatively
high vaccination rates
and now people are asking if this could
be the first real world evidence that
the pandemic in britain is sputtering
out
after three national lockdowns and
almost 130 000 deaths
public health experts alongside the
government predicted that cases would be
rising in britain at this point perhaps
even exponentially the highly contagious
delta
variant of the virus first detected in
india accounts for almost all new cases
there on july 17th
cases reach 54 600 the highest since
january
two days later dubbed freedom day by the
press prime minister boris johnson's
government ended all government mandates
in england for mass scoring and social
distancing
and everybody on the left lost their
bleep they lost it they said he was
going to kill everybody the delta
variant was going to murder everyone in
britain
all because of that evil boris johnson
and his crazy hair
some of the best infectious disease
modelers on the planet who weren't
totally wrong last year when they said
that 2.2 million people would die in the
united states like neil ferguson
the the always wrong epidemiologist from
the uk
some of the best infectious disease
modelers on the planet warned
a hundred thousand new cases a day this
summer could be expected
however the trend since then has been on
a sharp decline
scientists have theories maybe it's the
sunshine there was a week-long heat wave
yeah probably it's that schools have
closed for the summer break so children
are not spreading the virus as much
test and trace might be working
[Laughter]
testing test and trace ain't working in
a country with 50 000 new infections a
day guys
nope it's also possible people have
stopped getting tested because if they
test positive
even if they are fully vaccinated they
are asked to quarantine for 10 days
even if they are about to travel abroad
for their holidays or maybe britain has
reached an immunity threshold
more than 70 percent of adults here are
fully vaccinated 88
have had a first dose one of the best
vaccine uptakes in the world among those
who remain unvaccinated many have had
covetor asymptomatic infection
paul hunter professor of medicine at the
university of east anglia says britain
could be approaching population immunity
with people immune
either from vaccinations or natural
infection by the way
we should check those stats in the
united states vaccination plus
natural infection in the united states
we have got to be closing an unheard
immunity at this point
if you look at how many coveted
vaccinations we have done in the united
states
we have done at this point i'm looking
up the population stats
right now in the united states
approximately 58 percent of the
population has elite
has had at least one dose and 49.8
percent of the population 164 million
people
have been fully vaccinated in the united
states you take that 50
of the population and then you got to
add on top millions and millions of
covered infections that have already
happened many of whom didn't get
vaccinated afterward because they
believed they had natural immunity we've
got to be approaching herd immunity in
the same way that the uk does
martin mckee professor of european
public health at the london school of
hygiene and tropical medicine
said he doubted britain was reaching
population or hurt immunity in part
because that wouldn't explain regional
differences
i don't have a simple answer none of us
do he said
okay but hospitalizations and deaths are
rising in britain at least far slower
rate than during previous waves
more than six 000 coveted patients are
in the hospitals in britain that's the
highest figure since march
on wednesday britain reported 91 new
deaths
in 91 new deaths in a country of
approximately 67 million people that is
not a big number
and we're seeing the same so again the
media coverage here is just egregiously
bad
if you if you look at the situation in
israel for example there are people in
israel
oh my god it's crisis time in israel
like wow so many people
in israel having serious you know
hospitalizations
and and it's really it's really a
problem okay i'm looking
at the deontay numbers in israel of cove
deaths the seven day average of covert
deaths in israel
won according to johns hopkins
university
one well we're going to keep doing this
we're going to keep doing this we have
to keep doing this because there's no
end point
there never was an end point and this
pisses me off it really does
because for those of us who are data
driven this entire time
we're willing to do what it took to keep
ourselves and our families
safe all we asked was some sort of
rationale for why you are doing what you
are doing
you know if you're going to ask me to
restrict my liberty i want an
explanation of why my liberty ought to
be restricted if you don't give me that
explanation
and you demand that i continue to
restrict my liberty
no the answer is going to be no and i
think more and more americans are saying
no i think this
i think we're done i mean the american
people i don't think we're going to
tolerate this maybe they will
in places like new york where apparently
they love having idiot bureaucrats in
control
or l.a where you need barbara farrar who
knows as much about science as my
seven-year-old
figuring out how many people should mask
but
it's me it is maddening it's absolutely
maddening okay meanwhile
joe biden continues to daughter around
uh
it is incredible how we are the the
democratic party is now completely
reliant
on the continued durability of a man who
clearly
is uh is losing it here was the
president of the united states yesterday
saying that he ran for three reasons but
he can only remember two i remember when
this killed rick perry's presidential
campaign when he did something similar
but apparently it's no problem when
sitting presidents of the united states
can't put things together
when i i said i was running when i
announced my campaign
and not many people took it seriously i
said i was running
for three reasons one to restore the
soul of this country a sense of decency
and honor
but secondly to rebuild the backbone of
the country
hard-working middle-class folks
who built this country okay
so um that's that's great he can't
remember basic things
also polls show that joe biden is in a
bit of trouble
as he should be according to a brand new
poll six in 10 americans say that they
blame
joe biden for trouble on inflation
according to mediaite
20 voters said his economic policies
were somewhat responsible according to
this new study conducted for politico by
morning consult another 39
said the policies were very responsible
said they didn't know only 28 of
americans said that joe biden's policies
were not too responsible or not
responsible at all for the surge
in inflation inflation has continued to
surge
the bureau of labor statistics indicated
food prices increased significantly in
the month of june alone
including the cost of beef which is up
4.5 percent eggs 3.1 percent milk
0.05 home prices have also increased
setting record year-over-year growth of
in may in fact jerome powell who is the
head of the federal reserve he said yeah
by the way you know we were saying that
inflation is transitory and all that um
what we meant was it's not transitory
here's jerome powell the process of
reopening the economy is unprecedented
as was the shutdown at the onset of the
pandemic
as the reopening continues bottlenecks
hiring difficulties and other
constraints
could continue to limit how quickly
supply can adjust
raising the possibility that inflation
could turn out to be higher
and more persistent than we expect oh
well
no big deal though it's all good
everything's good in fact the new york
times has an entire piece today
about how isn't it magical that when we
just give people money
that we alleviate poverty they have a
big big piece in the new york times by
jason deparle today quote pandemic aid
programs spur a record drop in poverty
the most comprehensive study yet of the
federal response to the pandemic shows
huge
but temporary benefits for the poor it
helps frame a larger debate over the
role of government see here's the thing
according to the left the way you solve
poverty is you just drop bags of cash on
people
according to the right the way that you
solve poverty is you incentivize people
to make better decisions for their
family that allow them to climb
the rungs of success that's permanent
you want to get people out of poverty
you incentivize them to get jobs
you incentivize them to get educated you
incentivize them to make responsible
financial decisions according to the
left
the way that you make people not poor is
you drop
fiat money on them and inflate the
currency and apparently this is supposed
to
by the way there are consequences to
that here is one of the consequences
the brand new q2 gdp growth stats are
out today
they were expected to be 8.5 percent
right record massive
growth that was the expectation 8.5 8.4
percent
the economy instead grew at a pitiful
6.5
in the last quarter so the economist
only missed
by 25 there are 400
000 initial jobless claims
that is a huge gdp miss it is a huge
gdp miss and that gdp miss
the democrats going to blame that on the
covet uptech it is not due to the cove
uptick
it is due to the government botching
covid and it is due to the public health
messaging and
it is due to the fact that you are
paying people to stay home and it is
suppressing economic growth
you're inflating the currency or
inflating prices demand is starting to
decline
because you have inflated the prices and
because productivity is not
ramping up to meet demand all of this
is policy policy is what is doing this
right now
if you just left everything it's f the
entire democratic party
was going around shouting build back
better we got to build bet you know
that's the thing
build that you didn't even build back to
regular
when they say build back better what
they mean is what if we used this
pandemic as an excuse to dismantle
all of the institutions of success that
had created a historically prosperous
economy in march of last year what if we
just dismantled all of that and then
built it back better instead here's what
you get
you get my seven year old building a
beautiful structure
with her blocks and then my one and a
half year old coming in wrecking it
and then stacking two blocks and being
like i built back better this is what
you have done
if you are the democratic party at this
point that is a
terrible miss 6.5 growth versus 8.5
growth not even close not even close
and this is because of the battery it is
because they've blown money into this
economy at unbelievable record rates
that were unnecessary you know most
people in america
ended the pandemic with more in savings
than they started the pandemic with
that's how much money we spent and joe
biden's plan after that was
instead of telling everybody to get back
to work his plan was
what if we just keep giving you money
like forever and the new york times
they're cheering it on like good little
idiots they are
quote the huge increase in government
aid prompted by the covid pandemic will
cut poverty nearly in half this year
from pre-pandemic levels
and push the share of americans in
poverty to the lowest level on record
according to the most comprehensive
analysis yet of a vast but temporary
expansion
of the safety net the number of poor
americans is expected to fall by nearly
20 million from 2018 levels a decline
of almost 45 percent the country has
never cut poverty so much in such a
short period of time and the development
is especially notable since it defies
economic headwinds
the economy has nearly seven million
fewer jobs than it did before the
pandemic
yes because the way that you saw poverty
according to the left is you just shovel
meaningless dollars at people
which is not a medium or long-term
solution to poverty
it has never been a medium or long-term
solution to poverty to just shovel money
at people
it exacerbates over the long-haul
systemic poverty
it it creates incentives for people to
make worse financial decisions
it reduces growth rates it gets rid of
incentive for entrepreneurs to create
new businesses and better products and
services
the joe biden is going to feel the the
burden here he really is
the democratic party has blowback coming
2022 is going to be a very bad
year for them it's the reason why
they're so reliant on the january 6th
commission
because if at any point the american
people look around and realize
that we shouldn't be in a slow growth
mode here we should be in the fastest
growth
probably ever thanks to the artificial
coma the economy was put in last year
and now it's being blown
by the incompetence of a spend first tax
later administration
yeah the american people are not going
to react well to this
in any way shape or form all right we'll
be back here later today with an
additional hour of content coming up
soon as the matt wall show it airs at 1
30 pm eastern be sure to check it out
over at dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavel wydowsky
associate producer bradford carrington
host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 2021
john vickley here editor-in-chief of
daily wire wake up every morning with
our new show
morning wire on today's show the biden
administration moves to impose
federal vaccine mandates canadian
churches are targeted by arsonists
and the supreme court agrees to hear a
case that could impact roe v
wade join us and get the facts first on
the news you need to know
with our show morning wire